[Music]
hello and welcome to fantasy and reality
and today we'll be looking at the very
interesting and very human phenomenon of
narrative so from fairy tales to harry
potter from avatar to james bond you
seem to love fantasy and we expect our
books and our films our movies and
remedies to take us there
but at the same time we want our poems
and our plays and our novels in our
movies to affect life as it really is
so
should admiratives be seeking to uncover
reality by seeking to escape from it
or is it
simply the fact that any reconciliation
of those ideas are impossible is
impossible
are we on the one hand only unable to
create a narrative that sells things as
they really are and on the other hand
making a fantasy that has nothing to do
with our current circumstances there is
a difference or similarity why
well we have three people joining us for
the debate this afternoon i think are
very well positioned to try and uh you
know breathe some senses it's rather
confusing
first of all is a filmmaker sophie fines
i think his film director producer uh
she was also the producer one of my
all-time favorite psychiatric must
watches the pervert's guide to the
cinema which is written and presented by
the philosopher and psychoanalyst
celebrity
betty sue flowers has been a pioneer of
the psychological appreciation of
mythology alongside the esteemed joseph
campbell because she worked for many
years in a very productive collaboration
but he sue explores in homework the
influence of what these myths and
stories have in our lives today
and noah carol is a distinguished
professor of philosophy at the city
university of new york graduate center
he's known as one of the most important
config for contemporary figures in the
philosophy of art
what we're going to do today really is
explore the starting theme which is this
should our narratives be seeking to
uncover reality or seeking to escape
from it because i could ask you to start
with the uh the opening lines of your
pitch
when my son was about five he said mom
is there anything
bigger than infinity
and i said um i don't think so
i don't think so because infinity is all
of reality
there's nothing bigger than all of
reality
but the next day i ask a
mathematician friend of mine
the same question and he said oh sure
in set theory infinity plus one
so i think of narrative as the plus one
of infinity of reality
it neither uncovers or escapes
it creates reality the extra plus one
now reality is really weird very weird
we have such limited equipment to access
it
we have our senses
uh we have um
we have math which is even weirder than
reality in some respects because the
mathematicians play their little games
and then a hundred years later we see
wow that it's their games that they
played totally distinct from reality
actually map on to reality and we're
here in zoom world uh because of ones
and zeroes
so
reality being as strange and as
estranged from us and our limited
equipment to access it
um narrative becomes really important
it's the plus one
it creates reality we we live in story
we can't
experience our lives apart from
narrative we're the storytelling animals
we can't live in math we live in stories
so uh we even dream in stories
and our life is a story because it ends
in death it has a beginning and a middle
and an end and that's what gives it
meaning
so
i um
i have a hard time with both uncovering
and
escaping because i think we are creating
realities through our stories
that
have never existed before and have
always existed before because that's the
nature of reality you can't escape it
you can't uncover all of it we're
infinity plus one where the plus one of
infinity narrative is
thank you
no i'll never hear your pitch
i think i agree at least in certain as
uh respects with uh betty sue uh i'm a
little uh uneasy with the distinction
between realism or fantasy uh escapism
or discovery uh sometimes fantasy
actually in virtue of uh its capacity to
depart from
realism uh actually uncovers uh reality
i i think especially of uh rod sterling
who's famous for the twilight zone
uh he very often well in his career
he wanted to make uh more or less a
series of
critical
social
tv programs but was blocked uh because
of the advertisers but he discovered
that he could actually restage these
things in the twilight zone uh he also
did it with his script for uh
planet of the apes uh planet of the apes
addresses all kinds of questions of of
social justice
uh of uh of enslavement uh of the
education of the enslaved uh but it does
it in a very interesting way which is
what uh
fantasy genres can do
uh it puts it into a context where for
example
white white white viewers don't have to
feel uh that that
they're under attack uh they don't have
to feel as though uh they uh
are actually being accused of something
uh they can be detached in a way from
their ordinary interests and anxieties
and in a way that allows them to kind of
uh
think of these issues of justice in a
very disinterested and and more accurate
kind of way
um
the same thing happens in in the harry
potter series with its with its race war
uh so that in a in a curious way
fantasy can really probe reality uh and
and the other direction of course
don't don't forget that what we're
calling realism can also uh supply us
with escapes uh uh after all uh think of
uh celebrity biographies uh we could
read them to uh
escape our our daily uh burdens or
um think of the film chariots of fire
about you know a celebration of the of a
sporting event from years ago or uh any
kind of uh sporting history uh those are
uh as good a a an escape for reality
device as uh uh as a marvel comic book
so um as i say i'm i'm a little unhappy
uh i don't think we have as strict uh a
dichotomy here as uh uh
as
was set up with the question
cynthia yes well i completely agree with
nola i don't see these things as
oppositional
um i mean i i don't know about anyone
else here but i i find reality very hard
to be in any way i never feel fully in
reality i don't i think it's impossible
to it's a word but it doesn't mean the
experience of being human
and as a documentary filmmaker i'm of
course in supposedly the real world yet
as soon as i film the real world it's
not real anymore in fact it becomes
freighted and loaded with all kinds of
possible senses
um that might be to do with what i've
kind of culturally absorbed
as in terms of how i see what i see so
i mean i don't i feel that narrative is
is something that we can it was before
distinguishing narrative from fantasy as
this question is that narratives
are to me kind of quite crude methods
for how to bring
this complicated experience of reality
into some kind of order
um i i enjoy the films that push me out
of the neatness of narratives or plots
that
of the other the mainstay of fiction
and i'm i'm ready to kind of
fall into these kind of strange the
strange experience of
of reality which if i was trying to
think about this before
really
it's just when we're in times we're able
to be
in the moment of time that's as real as
it can be and that's really hard for us
i mean that's what you know you have to
meditate and
push everything out of your head to be
actually in the present moment in
in the now and when something of the
real in the sense of something traumatic
happens
the first thing we do is we come out of
our bodies the first thing we say is i
don't i did i felt i left my body
or time slowed down when we really
encountered something
really real like death or
like giving birth uh you know so the
these experience so the nature of
reality is already
a kind of uh it doesn't exist in a
simple way
um of course at the same time
you know fictions today are
you know fascinated by
the idea of reality which is like no mad
land is a good example of that because
it's a film that tries to bring fiction
and
reality
together in a seamless way
and you can see that our narrative is
used to sort of try to make that happen
thank you
if i may then pick up because really
what you've said i think very much takes
us into the first part of the
what we're about to talk about this
evening you've drawn attention to the
blurry nature of reality noel's drawing
attention the fact that wandering away
from reality into imagination can be a
very powerful way of making it more real
so can i ask um first of all i'm
actually might touch on a definition of
narrative and the definition of reality
if we dare come up with one but is it
possible therefore for a narrative
whatever that means to describe reality
whatever that means
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you